[Music]
super far from so much of the world in
the Central Asian region Kazakhstan the
biggest landlocked country
[Music]
this city when you find two is overly
impressive because the plane drops out
of the sky and then these mountains you
start to see these massive mountains so
it's got this frontier like wild feel to
it quiet Saturday morning business
buildings nothing not interesting yet
I'm gonna take one of these buses here
and just see where that takes me
almaty just like so many of these former
Soviet places are just rife with extreme
so is that Russian Orthodox Church
behind me and then check this out this
is just a pretty extreme monument I've
seen a lot of monuments of my time but
this one is in its own category world
war ii memorial and so for those that
don't know the soviets lost upwards of
25 million maybe more in world war ii
and all the states all this xov
assessor's 15 of them in total were
represented and well kazakhstan being a
big player in the war so I came here 16
years ago and that was we're gonna go
skating with Vasily a quick trip through
I was with a friend I was a kid and we
were just I think we're only here three
nights and basically just going out and
partying seeing some of the sights don't
remember too much of the place should
give some background update this guy in
a bland army during the week
it sounds like an killed you mean seven
years altogether in Red Army lived in
Alaska this is the warrior spirit ready
this time coming in to Almaty I've
gotten to get to know the city better
and I'm properly surprised by a lot of
beautiful streets in the city a lot of
wide boulevards very clean bike paths
I've seen a lot of these bike paths
outdoor patio areas restaurants coffee
shops green spaces it's actually green I
thought it would have been brown in the
summer but it's not even though it's
it's ridiculously hot right now out
there it's peaceful it's it's
everything's gridded and spread out so
it's it's a walkable city but the
distances are pretty large what I find
very interesting here is the mix of
ethnicities so you have a minority
Russian population and a majority Kazakh
population I think the Russians make up
I was told like roughly thirty thirty
five percent so it's a pretty large
demographic and it really gets along
well everyone I talked to and from what
I could notice on the streets it's like
the races intermingle very well and
Russian is mostly what I've heard on the
streets I haven't heard so much Kazakh
but there doesn't seem to be any tension
between the groups and that can't be
said in all countries in the world where
there's you know two two large
ethnicities in one place usually one's
the inferior one's a superior it just
feels like it works here really well
[Music]
I couldn't
Uber's not so popular they have
something called the index but more
effective actually it's just you hold
your your arm out you're gonna take a
taxi home yeah but it's Adam
but it's not a normal text you just sew
in in almaty you just put your hand out
yeah and negotiate a taxi yeah and
that's it
yeah and anyone picks you up yeah and
it's not hitchhiking so I learned that
it's actually there are tons of people
just cruising around and they're gonna
pick you up for extra cash and there's
enough trust in the city where that it
works I mean women do it at night which
I found to be interesting
it's a Petro State so there's a lot of
oil and gas here a lot of natural
resources and even though I've been told
it's very corrupt at least you can see
some of the money filtering down to the
infrastructure because the highways the
bridges the Metro is beautiful the
cleanest Metro I've ever been in by far
immaculate it's just really buff
[Music]
highly sleep-deprived right now because
[Applause]
and it's men and women out there and so
it is somewhat of a drinking culture
okay I want to talk about that everyone
party so we're in we're in a Muslim
country you can't be religious you can't
be not really just and I've been till I
met a few guys that are practicing on a
regular basis and they don't drink but
it doesn't mean everyone doesn't drink
it's a it's very tolerant and I've seen
a lot of Russian Orthodox churches here
so the religions seem to flow pretty
well together too it doesn't seem like
they're any rifts with that from what
I've noticed there's Hotel Kazakhstan
yes is your hotel on the money do you
love your country
oh cool beautiful place okay
I was told the salaries are pretty low
he said the the minimum salary is
roughly three hundred dollars a good
salary is like six hundred dollars a
great salary is like a thousand dollars
this is a month
then how is how do so many people have
nice cars why does everything look so
good
how do people have so much money I don't
get it something's not I don't know
sometimes I ask myself about these and
again corruptions a big part of that
sure but it's just something isn't
linked up there I can't figure that one
out I went to a so-called bad
neighborhood it wasn't terrible this is
the bad part of all Monty right I mean
the roads are still amazingly good which
is interesting is there a worst part
because it's early morning
it's dangerous at night it's definitely
a different world than where we were
the other side of the city up near the
mountains but still it's not like
terrible you ready
towba go there's a mountain coke tobei
which is up over the city and there's a
gondola the modern gondola that goes up
there and it gives these beautiful
viewpoints of the whole city
[Music]
now just rip right out of this city
massive snow-capped peaks it's on so the
Jataka love this stuff so much of this
in this part of the world
kids jumping just overall a good vibe up
here right over the city and what it
cost me six bucks to get up here yeah
it's super easy you know a lot of people
skip this part of the world usually they
go over the trans-siberian railroad and
so they miss all these Stan countries in
these Stan countries really in my
opinion some of the most interesting
ones I mean just these mountains alone
this is pretty much the start of the
Hindu Kush which goes all the way to
Everest so it's a mass I mean it's the
world's biggest mountain chain
[Music]
so the city has all these irrigation
canals and it all is coming from these
mountains so it's really fresh cold
water people dip their feet in it they
hang out it cools the air in the city
even though it's it's super hot it
definitely cools off the place a bit you
put the word stand at the end of
anything any word or sentence and a
majority of Americans or say Western
Europeans are thinking terrorism dangers
it's not the case here not at all
it's got a bad image because of
partially because of the name partially
because it's been you know just
destroyed through the movie bora so
people have a bad impression of this
place which is which is completely
unjust because as you can see in my
footage it's a good looking place it's a
pleasant place it's like a nice it's
like a nice city you couple in this this
kazakh / russian / being very landlocked
sort of beteen europe and asia massive
mountains in them and a forever plane
that leads into this place and you have
something quite unique it's not even
that adventurous which is crazy
everyone you know most people think the
cosmic Stan wow it's that's extreme
no no it's it's actually not I mean you
can ripoff into the countryside here and
I'm sure to get get into some serious
adventurers but as far as coming into
Almaty
it's a very civilized clean peaceful be
a nice place so that's my story